so should we screw around until one of
us dies the first time oh so much
that seems brilliant which one of you is
pretty boy which one of you is grandpa
i'm always brutal how do i make this
shut the hell up
you must be grandpa
how do i make this thing turn off i hate
it
hey we gotta go to the orphanage again
all right it's the same objectives as
before
now the wardrobe is different than
borley oh
that's different
i feel like i was picking hey guys
god damn it
what the hell
yeah it was quick that time that seems
kind of unfair honestly not unfair
that's [ __ ] i even turned around and
flashed him and he was like nah too late
why don't we just reboot that one that
was dumb let's restart we can oh
hilford village what's hilford village
is that out
explore hill fort village find the
mysteries of the secret item oh
that seems better than this crap it says
without entity
oh that's when we just explore the map
yeah no never mind that's dumb
do i have an invite
no
it's on its way do i have an invite can
i get an invite i don't see an invite
it's it's it's you both should have had
invited
me
[Music]
i don't even remotely believe you yeah
that's what you sound like i'm not
getting into the game though
can i get another invite
yeah yeah let me i'll send it right out
am i gonna learn you guys i don't wanna
play the game with you
is that the voice i used to order coffee
yeah whenever i order coffee i step out
of my car and go right up to the
drive-through thing and i go can i get a
coffee
[Applause]
it's the same god damn thing again it's
almost like this game doesn't have that
many objectives
there's like
all right i'm gonna listen on this emf
and or this uh parabolic and i'm gonna
see so good
here okay i'm gonna hear good where are
we going
i'm going into borla real quick since
we're right behind it are you old men or
or which one you know
oh
that's a lot of birds did you hear that
mark remember how we talked on an
episode of distractible at the birds
falling out of the sky oh wait no no
it's not enough they hurt us and they
made this game
you guys should listen to all right it's
coming i got it i hear nothing i hear
nothing i hear nothing i hear nothing i
hear nothing i hear nothing yeah i think
it might have been close i heard nothing
i don't think the parabolic microphone
works i don't think that's what it's for
man gotta be honest all right get your
crystal out go up the stairs
yes ma'am
let the first demon be the last
i'm upstairs i'm upstairs i push stairs
i push stairs i push stairs i'm looking
out the window i hear a baby i hear a
baby i hear stomping come here i hear
stomping
pushing downstairs i'm going downstairs
pushing down pushing down i'm pushing
i'm pushing perfectly splendid
oh there you go
look at this guy
i'm going to grab this i see a deer i
see a deer i see a deer there's a deer
it's got antlers it's good it's good
deer is good here's good cans you hit
cans you hit cans we're [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] yep we're probably [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] ceiling the door downstairs
ceiling door door is sealed
i'm not getting emf i got a little emf
and then i sealed the door and he left
all right church oh my god you guys oh i
thought you left me
i thought you left hey buddy how you
doing you've got
dark eyes
so do you i don't like it i don't like
it i don't like it i'm at the bridge
you're at the bridge you're pushing
bridge you're pushing the bridge
bridge pushing bridge
following following looking behind
looking behind there are bodies on the
bridge through my camera we're playing
call of duty right now i'm seeing things
uh pushing point pushing point
pulling uh getting shot from the left
shot from the left
oh you're gonna play pubg again
wait
[ __ ] up
oh
see that voice has a lot of uses
oh [ __ ] all right come on dude
come on church mark and i went the wrong
way because i followed marcus
yeah the all the way around the wrong
way the church
we're dumb we're stupid
don't worry man we'll be there in a
minute we're pushing our iq to the limit
enough to save my life
coming we're coming we're almost there
made it all the way around we all the
way around we're back we're behind you
mark mark mark where i don't see i don't
i see you
cool got it cool i flashed aren't you
glad i yelled at you yeah that was good
calls good call out
hey mark you can use your favorite toy
in here
my parabolic microphone oh wait you know
what that's not true i lied you need to
use your camera and look around the
church for a statue
that only appears in the camera mini mad
damn luna
did someone get the door i don't know
i'm watching the door right now but i
have no charge so if something comes
through the door i'll just be screaming
for one of you put the trap on the door
you dingus
you put the four on the door
put the four on the door and then no one
will ever come away
all right fine
it's called defense
boomer it's there okay
oh boomer
all right all right
is it downstairs
no it's it's uh up there going down
[Laughter]
is it downstairs no it stops i'm going
down
[Music]
like you're so interested in yourself
it's still up here with me
downstairs is so cool oh is there a time
limit on that yeah it goes away the more
you know
whoa what is this painting
what what is this painting what am i
looking at what am i what am i what am i
i gotta increase my field of view hang
on i'm so confused am i just seeing
someone bent over backwards or wait have
you seen we've all been there you know
what i'm saying you know what i'm saying
what
i'm saying
what what am i looking at
what am i looking at are those boobs i
think those are
i was i was like i'm very confused
before what am i looking at
[Laughter]
this field
wait i couldn't tell what was going on
with the upper half of the body but if
someone back bent backwards so their
boobs are just pointing like straight to
the ceiling and i couldn't my brain was
incapable of processing what i was like
everybody let's give a hand to mark for
seeing
[Applause]
oh man we grow up every day we grow up
every day man we grow up every day did
you really just honestly wander off
downstairs yeah i'm coming back i needed
a minute dang bob do you have a thing i
do where's it at
there i have it i got it oh i got it i
got it i got it i got it
did you find the thing yet
hey mark how's it going hey what's up
guys welcome did you find the thing ah
you know what gosh darn it we didn't how
in all of your complaining have you not
found it yet i was standing in a dark
closet just hiding biting my time okay
why why not
what are we looking for again some kind
of stats wait oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait all right
yeah i got it don't worry we all need
the charge up at the front so whoever
needs it grab it all right
i'll take that i'll take that okay
[Music]
could hardly even see it when you go to
this uh
the elevator all right right right the
orphanage um do i just jump down
yeah jump down jump down we're done
jumping down no iron legs
he likes to pop up down here for some
reason like in front of us
um
i doubt it i doubt it
i'm doubting he wouldn't have no balls
balls no balls
apparently that could have been 14.
he has balls he has balls
oh god oh god oh god popped up inside of
mark he did he really did i think i felt
him around me as he emerged
oh i get to i get to read the writing oh
wait what are we doing
okay yeah no more give us your version
of the writing all right you guys you
guys finished the orphanage while i read
you guys this okay okay uh
kimberly
crudi
the
institution
of
inquisition
made
and
takes
the i
out day
clearly it
george
way
ended
of said
county
i then
hammock
and
millie bobby brown
with
bobby brown odin nolan
and
then
edward
okay bob i'm upstairs i'm coming to the
right here it's
[Music]
i remember that word
i think i said that same thing i think
he did actually
and i'll get you
my name real quick before as soon as i
reset my
like a rick and morty thing oh the
mumbai i'm faith halton
yeah the plumbus go ahead and start
running the cemetery bubble i'm going to
start the altar thing all right i'll go
save faith thanks oh biscuits
oh i may have stepped in some glass
what's your name faith faith holton
glass faith
coming back buddy thanks buddy
thank you buddy
watch out you guys want me to just go do
the orphanage thing alone or do you guys
want to sure sure you're going gonna be
able to do it alone
yeah
okay the mystery of the mirror in
baldwin house
just like all great teams who hunt
ghosts we split up divide and conquer
let's go to the baldwin house
yep
baldwin this way yeah that way i'll
watch our backs
i'll watch in front of me
worst case i'm making a horrible mistake
i'm about to die i kick some cans i'm
distancing myself from mark
this is the
is this the orphanage
no baldwin house is over here
baldwin house dead ahead
i'm hoping that the cmf is going to give
me a little warning before something's
four diamonds
star
mustaches
what do you see
get inside
what is it the mystery of the mirror
with the camera okay wait we know that
that one do you have a thingy for the
trigger
oh i do
no i don't uh i'm just kidding
i see it
it's outside
by the well
okay the well my friend
there were cans on the porch that's not
a good thing to do bob come on bob come
on bob all right we did baldwin house
all right
we're good wait it's we're making a lot
of noise and it's not over here so
i'm just going to guess it's near you
you might be [ __ ] okay we need your
mind where's the door you're doing the
dormitory we need to go to church yes
i'm following you i'm trusting you okay
trust me trust me you're trusting me are
you going to old church or new church oh
is your church different there's church
and old church it just says andrew it's
back the wrong way it says just it just
says
i don't know yeah so we go to the one
that's just church not new okay oh okay
oh hey are you seeing the blood
yeah that's gushing
oh yeah snap a pic of that bad boy i
knocked over some bottles can i take a
shower
i emp yeah
the entrance is wait it's the other way
we did this before we did this before we
did this before which one are you guys
going to barley or
church church church church
all right to borley i go
all these cans around is a real dill
weed tell you what kind of an [ __ ]
come on hey guys i see you hey friends
oh hey what's up hey what's up this is
not borley get out listen oh hey mark
you want to use your favorite tool i
love my favorite tool
go go use it bro where's the cross
where's the cross uh at the front
obviously front at the front no no no no
where the cross goes
listening to the cross
[Music]
yeah is that pretty cool
to the cellar
oh i don't want to do that i'm going
down look there's some boobs oh
that's neat that's pretty cool he's got
boobs straight ahead there's boobs boobs
boobs 220 boobs 220. mark's second pair
of boobs uh ghost child
ghost child's 150 200.
dead south
oh ghost child open the cellar door oh
yeah no that's fine mark just go get
that
out of the door charge just a fed i have
a flash mark is my only salvation
we need to alter now right yo we need
one more we need one more oh hi buddy
i mean oh wait's doing borley though
right yeah what's going on what are you
smiling
oh
i didn't picture that that was adorable
look so we should go to an altar mark we
should go to an altar there's an altar
right here
so ready wait are you doing are you
doing borley bro yep you're boring
mark we should split up so if it if it
comes we split up and whoever whoever
lives does the altar
there you go
filter
you have a flash freak that yeah i
almost stand by you yesterday by me keep
me safe bro all right we're keeping you
safe keeping you safe oh it's a team to
be safe
oh it's a nice teddy bear that's a nice
one oh that is kind of nice
well done boys this is a loud one can i
just say that
take the entity's heart what does that
mean
we have to find the heart
i hear a heartbeat
oh i hear it i see it i hear it inside
oh i hear it and see it as well is it in
the orphanage
uh seems like it no
yeah no it's in like the top part of the
orphanage though
uh you said there was a front door right
there is i think we can go around wade
where are you
i'm coming back from borley okay you
gonna be okay
oh either that one mark what's that
sounds uh probably fine probably fine
it's probably fine
music's picking up uh yeah oh hey here
we go we're at the thingy
okay i'm going in i have flash yeah i
think we have to go in there
cam i'm around in these corners very
carefully
i'm i'm em effing behind you so
you're effing behind him i'm f in you
okay i'm gonna put uh my circle down
here in this little hallway
okay i don't have a circle i'm a liar
i'm lying i'm lying lying you're lying
lying
lies lies i'm lying liar i'm lying
nothing oh
okay let's push now let's push
pushing pushing pushing the heart
oh crack glass i'm an [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i can't see it
i don't see
anything uh
wrap around to your right
yep coming up approaching heart i think
approaching heart wade what's your name
what oh [ __ ] uh
oh final ritual eric sandy norton sandy
norton
uh
i think we need to go back outside mark
i think i want to go down you grab it
because it might have given you a flash
damn it okay oh yeah it's fine yeah
let's go uh not that way this way yeah
this way i don't think i've ever died on
the elevator before didn't you know oh
no that's kind of unfortunate that he's
very honest i don't even know you could
don't worry we'll come get you
uh yeah yeah that way yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
did it drop down does anyone know how i
died there what happened to me it
dropped down on me
that was weird
definitely weird big weird wait should
we get you or should we just trying to
win
no no
you got one flash mark we're gonna
really have to make this count i got a
flash on the floor
don't kick the things i will not kick
the things don't do it i'm not gonna do
it
good
sandy norton do you know where sandy
norton is mark um i don't know if the
name plates change or not
finn law
charles dickens
sandy norton okay
watching her back 1864.
i i did it
cool
sometimes you can get a duplicate i
think we want to go to the one two
hundred
wondered i think that's closer maybe
because it's a bigger icon yeah hard to
say well there's three of us so the odds
are one of us will make it right it must
be through that that door that was on
fire
and it is yeah it's no longer on fire
all right
i'm heads on swivel
no emf ratings right now no emps
oh this is not as straightforward as i
would have hoped
um
oh okay
okay uh pushing pushing the final ritual
area
pushing
pushing pushing
oh that's it
yep oh
well that was easy
this is going to pop only two
it might still pop it might still pop
it's going
oh
okay it's not satisfying
god that was one of the bigger jump
scares i've ever had in this game i did
not know you could die in the elevator
like that
uh
like dude on harder difficulties but
it's pretty much the same so we did it
we did it good job yeah
well done
that's good stuff right there yeah bob
you resurrected us both or you weren't
caught at all bob
no perfect game i think that's going to
do it for me today guys
all right
okay that's a nice little gaming set
[Music]